i want to start with this over the
holiday weekend after
a grueling year let's be honest it's
been a tough election year for everybody
like all of you and your family that
took time to reflect and part on the
current political landscape and that's
where we want to start tonight
and i want to share some of my key
conclusions and
i'm just telling you how i feel i don't
care i could care less
what the fake phony selective outrage
from the media
mob is i am not interested nor do i
think any of us should be interested in
what
they tell us they find offensive
uh the sanctimonious high-minded
phony concern all of a sudden about
american democracy
we frankly don't need lectures about
truth
about integrity from what is a depraved
group
of democratic donors the media mob
uh and democrats that never accepted the
results of 2016
ever i don't care what they think they
lied to you
and us for four years on the most
spectacular level
they drag this country through hell with
russian lies
conspiracy theories and a hoax they
pushed for years
it was all a lie they all advanced the
lie
they all advanced the conspiracy theory
there was never trump russia collusion
four investigations no collusion they
peddled that phony clinton bought and
paid for
dirty russian disinformation dossier
the one that i mentioned claimed that
donald trump
had hookers uh urinating in his bed
in the ritz carlton in moscow that's
what they
sold as truth to the american people for
three years
peddling those lies they had no problem
with the phony dossier
they never retracted the phony stories
they didn't care that that phony dossier
was used to secure fisa warrants
to spy on a presidential candidate and
then a president
for four years so all of you in the
media mop
oh this is a threat to democracy asking
questions about
election irregularities save us your
phony bs
lectures they are meaningless to the
rest of us you dragged this country
through hell
you did it again with your phony
ukrainian impeachment winch hut
and you totally ignored and protected
the real quid pro quo with joe
and zero experience hunter and the
family of biden and their massive
payouts
oh from the barista group a ukrainian
oligarch
a russian oligarch the first lady of
moscow the 1.5 billion dollar deal with
the bank of china
and of course shopping sprees from
chinese natural nationals
you shielded the weak frail cognitively
struggling joe
the entire election the 78-year-old guy
democrat was allowed to hide in his
basement bunker
the media that lectures us now they
allowed that
they were they were biden's attack dogs
they did the bludgeoning of trump for
biden so for the media there's no
honesty there's no fairness there's no
fidelity to truth
we don't need their lectures a
four-year-long effort they never
accepted
this president tried to delegitimize him
every second every hour of every day you
might remember
we are looking at the possibility that
the president of the united states
and those around him during an election
campaign
colluded with a hostile foreign power to
undermine
the basis of our democracy we're about
to find out if the new president of our
country
is going to do what russia wants this is
evidence of willingness to commit
collusion this cloud about collusion
with russia
will hang over him no matter where he
stands i can certainly say
with confidence that there is
significant evidence
of collusion between the campaign and
russia
i think what it means is that a federal
judge found that people in trump's
organization were colluding with the
russians
it does look like collusion it does look
like he's listening to putin more than
he is
american intelligence and frankly i've
never seen that before
now those same hacks are demanding that
we the american people
74 million strong just fall in line and
accept their new
standards and accept election results
without investigating
what are valid affidavits and claims by
fellow american citizens under the
threat of perjury
of fraud this is a bad joke
dizzying 12-hour period where the
president assaulted
dedicated civil servants while
simultaneously trying to undermine the
outcome of an election
about these tactics both by the
president and by his campaign and by
republicans who support him
that after an election elections
officials
are now subject to lobbying subject to
pressure subject to enticement or
um or threats like the only way to stop
that becoming the new normal at least in
republican politics
is for some people to go to jail for it
i never thought i'd see a day
where you saw pretty much an entire
party in this country
refused to accept election results
amazing how they changed
four years that they lied with russian
disinformation that hillary paid for
they're that out of touch that's the mob
that's why i call them the medium mob
they're not looking out for you they're
nothing more than a glorified overpaid
wing of the democratic party they're
their propaganda arm
they'll spread lies conspiracy theories
have their temper tantrums give us the
lectures
and i think we can take a few weeks to
investigate election irregularities
according to a poll new politico survey
nearly 80 percent of trump voters
believe this election was tainted with
fraud
and you have every right not to have
faith and confidence how come all these
other states got it right
we have a right to be concerned we'll
follow the facts we'll highlight
concerning allegations and
irregularities